deixe me aproximar do piano que andamos
sinto melhor
é bonita todos
tudo começou estava ainda na barriga da
minha mãe da minha mãe cantava para mim
cantar a missão de cantar um histórico
nos meses mais tarde quando vim ao mundo
para mim mesmo com sei quando nem o
mundo consegue ouvir por mim mesmo já
sem a ajuda da minha mãe e os mesmo
estar proferiu as primeiras palavras
tomar uma realidade que muito antes de
proferir qualquer som da palavra como em
um processo mais importante complexo
saber aprender a ouvir por volta dos
três anos juntamente com minha mãe e às
minhas tias comecei a freqüentar os
ensaios do grupo coral e à noite quando
não conseguiram ser a minha mãe cantava
canções de zeca afonso só finalmente aos
cinco anos de idade é que entra em uma
escola de música para aprender as
primeiras notas musicais
precisamente um ano antes de entrar na
escola primária para aprender as
primeiras letras e algarismos e da mesma
forma que quando eu entrei na escola
primária eu já comunicada minimamente
não seria o meu português
quando entrei em um ano antes na escola
de música eu já tinha começado muito
antes este complexo processo de aprender
a ouvir como disse um dia o maestro
cláudio a button
muita gente aprenda a falar mas pouca
gente aprendeu ver e ouvir uns aos
outros é uma coisa importante na vida ea
música ensina nos a fazer isso foi há
cinco é a língua portuguesa tornou-se na
minha língua materna alguma música
nesta fase surge um dilema na vida de
meus pais tinham dois filhos porque a
gente tinha acabado de comprar a casa
completamente remodelado em um
importante discurso ao piano rapaz tem
talento precisa de um plano para ajudar
mas com os meus pais nem sabem do seu
vai fazer esta profissão
a realidade é que nos parecia não
arriscar e compraram 1
o incremento e dois anos mais tarde não
tiveram medo compra não viu imprimir
mesmo que estou vendo que ela jamais
iria fazer isto porque são simplesmente
sentiram que a música seria o importante
nas nossas vidas
e foi assim que plantamos vive em uma
casa completamente mobilado mais
preenchida por sons do meu piano e os
sons do rio além da minha irmã
um ano após ter começado os meus estudos
neste novo instrumento
eu já tocava minha primeira obra prima
neste caso um produto e onde sebastian
bar suava usando
[Música]
há uma história por volta dos 7 8 anos
tocava minha primeira obra de chopin
neste caso noturno em dó sustenido menor
sou algo no gênero
e finalmente aos 89 anos sobre as
primeiras páginas do conselho pp e
orquestra do rodrigo
pessoal só algo assim
[Música]
é
consegue imaginar a fornecer alguma
criança do casal tão mole com um chope e
autônoma de tozzo como levar cristo
aprender música é prender uma linguagem
uma linguagem completamente nova
inicialmente parece tudo muito
complicado
aprendemos letra a letra pois juntamos
as letras e temos uma palavra juntamos
as palavras e termos uma frase
juntamos as frases temporários juntamos
parágrafo sentimos um capítulo e
finalmente juntarmos os capítulos e
formamos um livro inteiro e é este livro
inteiro este todo cheio de notas
musicais que nós não nos impressionarmos
partitura e são essas partituras que nós
músicos somos ensinados desde muito
pequenos aprenderam que cobre o meu
repertório musical foi desenvolvendo
paralelamente ao meu repertório
literário como sempre coisas muito
simples record mulher com a minha mãe
com destino ao brasil na colômbia
dinamarca floriano
mais tarde o principezinho você for
fazer a repórter na consciência e só
anos mais tarde muito preocupa uma
disciplina chamada literatura portuguesa
é que os grandes clássicos da nossa
língua como jorge camões 1917 era o
marco é fácil esta conexão entre a
literatura ea música porque uma não vive
sem a outra
na realidade toda a arte está
interligado entre si as criações
artísticas de todos até um gênio que ao
longo da história foram passando a
humanidade imortalizados com as suas
obras por exemplo o iptu
ouvimos as beleza das palavras do inglês
opções bettoni
se olharmos para obras do mini challenge
houve nada 20
ouvimos as grandes páginas da obra de
onde você em barra
a tempestade de shakespeare
sentimos absurdo na cabeça da moça por
exemplo na hora apropriada para piano do
franz lizst sonata quase uma fantasia
não dizem em português após uma leitura
dentro ser um dia completamente
impossível compreender o conteúdo esta
obra se antes não tivéssemos lei de obra
abundante divina comédia
da mesma forma usar tocar os netos de
troca do compositor franz liszt sem
antes ler os netos do próprio troca
seria um erro grosseiro
o último exemplo os compositores
impressionistas franceses rafael índice
certamente que tenham sofrido um
percurso bem diferente da época não
tivessem surgido pintores
impressionistas franceses como o nema
nenê o degas todos estes gênios chamaram
me olharam e mortal visando com isso com
as suas obras tornando os irmãos entre
si
mas agora vocês dizem pedro todos esses
nomes são complexos respeito a mim que
eu quero mesmo é ouvir tocar música o
engenheiro sem problema nenhum não tem
nenhum problema quanto a isso agora a
música com deficiência é com um vasto
oceano e cada um de nós decidir o aluno
inscreveu-se no lugar de ficar só pela
música ligeira significa ficar os álbuns
pela costa
eu estive no lugar por esse mar adentro
e nada mas depende da música torna um
dos melhores pessoas
está provado que tocar um instrumento
musical
melhoramos a nossa coordenação gramas
nossa concentração melhoramos a nossa
capacidade de leitura e de interpretação
do país
tornamos parceiros garante mais
autonomia às melhores ouvintes mas acima
de tudo tornamos mais foi isso a nós
mesmos e aqui no colégio mas tudo isto
são coisas sobre as quais não queria
focar porque basta vocês pesquisar no
google encontraram todos os benefícios e
tocar um instrumento musical luz por 3 a
este é o lado material da música eu
preferia falar sobre o avaí material da
música quando eu tive a minha primeira
aula foi minha professora vera agora
nossa tarefa conquistei durante seis
anos em moscou ela disse uma frase que
eu não
compreender não compreendia a primeira
mas que nunca mais esquece
ela diz pedro a música não é de resto a
música não é material
a música real e metafísica
como é que você quer em nfc que este
instrumento é feito de madeira metal não
é nada demais real concreto e palpável
do que um piano é um objeto como outro
qualquer mas a capacidade que este
instrumento tem de produzir sons que não
são deste mundo tyson ea e metafísicos
isso é que torna este instrumento
verdadeiramente único especial como diz
não é aos professores da minha
professora e selva lago nas mãos do
pianista são uma extensão do seu
intelecto e extensão do seu coração
deste jeito isso significa que o piano
goiano a capacidade intelectual e
capacidade espiritual tem nem toca e é
isso que torna este instrumento
verdadeiramente único especial por isso
se algum dia um filho voz
façam como alguns países um dia fizeram
dele um instrumento musical para as mãos
e por falar a gente nem sempre se
entendeu ter dinheiro ou seja não língua
realmente no homem da música
[Aplausos]
[Música]